for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy so
what's the take-home point of this
series on the pathways of amino acid
oxidation it's really that we can get
energy out of breaking down amino acids
and the way we do that is by first
removing the nitrogen as an ammonium ion
and that'll make its way of course to
the urea cycle to be removed or excreted
safely as urea once we remove that
nitrogen we get the carbon skeleton
which of course can loan way or another
eventually give us a key product that
can go through the TCA cycle and of
course from there going through the GC a
cycle it gives us some nadh fadh2 and
GTP all of which are valued at energy
okay so this video it's titled summary
but it really isn't a summary it's more
like a recommendation as to what I think
you should go back and do as far as
studying when it comes to this path
these pathways one thing that you should
pay closer attention to is the how we
created nadh --is and fadh2 s sort of
along the way to converting the carbon
skeleton into the key product right
whatever that key product was whether it
was acetyl co a pyruvate alpha cubed
would raise a section of co a
oxaloacetate femur a ball a lot the
point is that um it wasn't just once a
the key product was formed that we
started to get nadh and fadh2 s we got
some editing nadh and fadh2 is on the
way to converting the carbon skeleton to
one of those key products so that's one
thing that's important another thing to
pay attention to is the fact that we
actually remove the neck surgeon and in
more ways than one right a lot of the
times it was transamination reactions
there was also a glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction with Tammany's reaction and
some others in there as well okay
also pay attention to the role that one
carbon transfer reactions play one
carbon transfer reactions and the
cofactors using them biotin
tetrahydrofolate s-adenosylmethionine
they are important
okay also in the videos I didn't I
didn't really talk too much about
whether an amino acid was ketogenic
cuoco genic after that one video that
sort of defined them and listed them so
one thing that I would recommend that
you do is go back and basically pay
attention to how the ketogenic and gluco
genic amino acids like how precisely
they go from being that amino acid to
arriving at their key products like how
did for instance leucine or lysine how
did those guys specifically become
acetyl co a or with it when it comes to
the glucose genic amino acids how do
they specifically give rise to these key
products right since we define Mukul
genic and ketogenic in that one video I
think was a second video I didn't
actually go through in each video and
say oh this amino acid is ketogenic this
amana amino acid it's cuoco genic let's
see how it's broken down so maybe if you
go back and take your notes from the
second video and apply that to you know
the other videos actually show the
pathways that might be useful and
helpful to you anyway I hope this video
was helpful I hope this series was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends
thank you and happy studying